Speaker 1: Hey, this. You have to see a Fox News
guest. Stacy Washington, Sirius radio host says
that one of the reasons why we are seeing more
lawlessness in the United States is that when
you go to hotels now, they don't always have
those Bibles in the nightstand. That's the
introduction. Let's listen to what she said.
Speaker 3: Will they be? I'll tell you what
will happen, because it's New York. Unless you
basically murder someone, you don't get in trouble
here. They're in hoodies. They're in masks. Will
we ever even find out who did this? If we were,
they would be either charged as juveniles
or they'd be right back out on the streets.
Speaker 4: That's right. And to Ainsley's point,
they see these businesses, these ones that are
open now are the ones that survived COVID.
They survive the absolutely mind boggling
costs imposed upon them by the government to make
sure that they complied with COVID regulations.
The decrease in customers and customers because
of the lockdown in the pandemic, now they're
finally back on their feet. They're dealing with
heightened taxes from this administration. They're
dealing with zero foot traffic, massive rent
payments, because states like this are trying
to make up for the lack of revenue and just to
get their business destroyed and potentially
their livelihood. And one five minute fell swoop.
Speaker 5: So you see the increase in lawlessness
when we take God out of everything. So
we're so far down the control on that.
And I'm talking about the fact that if you stay
in a hotel anywhere, you can't even find a Bible
in the nightstand anymore. Now, admittedly, the
Bible is on the top, but it's just a thing that.
Speaker 1: Isn't that amazing. So I have
to admit, I am partially to blame for
there not being as many Bibles and hold hotel
nightstands anymore when I go into a hotel.
When I look in the nightstand, if there is a
Bible there, I put it out in the hallway like
your room service tray that you're done with.
I take it out. I don't want it in the room. I
admit that I do this now. Sometimes I'll put
it in the recycling bin, but my instinct is
that the housekeeping staff probably takes it out
and puts it back in the nightstand. I don't know.
But my move is to take the Bible and to put it in
the hallway, and then it disappears. I just don't
want it in the room with me. Now, where did these
Bibles come from? This goes back to actually 1899.
There's a group called the Gideons International,
and it was two traveling salespeople, Samuel Hill
and John Nicholson. And they started you know,
they wanted to spread the word of God, I guess,
to as many people as possible. They thought
hotel rooms are the place because you've got
people there traveling or whatever. They might not
have access to a Bible. So you stick a Bible there
and next thing you know, instead of going out and
hiring a prostitute or seeking drugs, they'll say,
I'm going to stay in and read the Bible and so
on and so forth. And so this started sometime
between 1899 and 1908, and the Gideon's started
distributing these. There are other groups that
now do it as well. But Gideon's is the big
one. So my movies blame me for it. Blame me
for the lawlessness. I will if I find one of
the Bibles. Put it in the hallway. It's not
part of the hotel room that I am looking. You
know, double vanity, rain shower, shower, head
free. WI fi. I'm right there with you. A
couple of free Fiji waters, maybe. I love it.
I don't need the Bible in the room with me,
so I put it out in the hallway. I guess I'm
responsible for the crime wave in New York City.